what is going on everybody welcome to
part 14 of our Python with PI QT for GUI
application development tutorial video
series in this video we're going to be
talking about how can we open up a file
so it turns out that built within QT is
a file picker so to speak where we can
pull it up and actually choose a file
from our operating systems kind of
directories so that's pretty cool
because it's built right in to QT so
let's just go ahead and jump in because
how can we have an editor if we don't
have a file to edit that doesn't make
any sense so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna add another bit like we've
got open editor well also we want to
have is like file open so we want to be
able to go like open file for example
and we'll say that is equal to and in
fact let's just copy and paste all of
this that would make a lot of sense and
and then just start renaming stuff so
open file copy paste paste paste instead
of control e that would make sense to be
control o we're gonna make this open
file and then status tip can be open
file and then the triggered method will
be file underscore open and that should
be it the only other thing of course we
need to add it to the file menu so what
we'll do is file menu dot add action and
we want to add open file so open file
awesome now we need to add our fight or
what do we call that method file open
let's just copy and paste forget it
scrolling on down we add another method
what's oh dear
we always made a huge mess of the place
uh we were gonna do it I don't know
let's do it right here so define file
actually spaced yeah file open and then
it was past self and now you're ready to
go so first of all we have a name in a
file so first we'll say the name here is
going to be equal to Q T GUI equals q TQ
e dot Q file dialog dot get open
file name self and then this will be the
title basically to the little window
that pops up and we'll title it open
file then we're gonna say file equals
open whatever that name is and we're
gonna open it with the intention to read
okay so then so when you when we open
this file
what are we opening the file for so we
can open it and we can read it in or
well this is just opening it with the
intention to read we haven't actually
read a thing but it so the nails let's
go even past that so we know we want to
open the file what do we want to do with
it well we want to load it into that
text editor and then up here how do we
get that file name this just it's the
file dialog built in the Qt and whatever
file we pick that's being returned as
the file name
done so anyway moving right along after
we have the file name what do we want to
do well first of all we're gonna call
self dot editor why are we calling self
dot editor we need the editor to be
there if you recall the editor is not
there by default right we were going
like show editor so if we don't call
self dot editor it won't be there the
file will load and we can even populate
the editor with the stuff but until we
call you know to set it as a central
widget and all that now it won't
actually show up anywhere
so anyways now we'll say with file we're
gonna say text equals file dot read and
then we're gonna say self dot text edit
dot set
next text and that should be all we need
text edit you just make sure even was
texted I don't even know we're gonna run
this and see how it works okay so first
of all I want change to may be plastique
so pretty now first let's just open the
editor cool so the editor works now
let's try open file and then here are
the list of videos that we're writing
right now how about we open the same one
that we're making right now do it here
it is
lovely lovely so there is our file
that's pretty cool if these things
excite me whenever you finally that get
to this point and you're like wow that's
awesome it worked anyway so that's cool
and it's a pretty good-looking editor I
mean we have this babyface I mean that's
nice
anyway but just just just admire the
beauty of Pi QT all the things that we
have so far and this is a pretty darn
good-looking window you just want to
have a good looking window like this if
you had tkinter so anyways now we have
the editor we can open a file and again
you've got this nice file picker that is
like already there for you it's easy
easy to use and all that so anyways
let's close out of this and now the next
and final thing that we really need to
do to finish up this little editing
application that we've built for
ourselves is we need to be able to save
the file to whatever we want so this
we're going to be talking about in the
next video so if you have any questions
or comments up to this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time